BOO!
Well hello there, boils and ghouls!
We hope we didn’t startle you too hard there,
it’s only us, your good old friends at SCP
Explained.
We all love a little fright now and then,
don’t we?
After all, that would explain our fascination
with the morbid tales of the SCP Foundation.
Rotten old men who can walk through walls,
and tear you limb from limb in their own private
hells?
Nightmarish Sarkic diseases that turn anyone
who touches them into a horrible abomination?
Evil masks that kill you and take over your
body, using it to do acts of great cruelty
until you melt down into black goo?
Oh...You’re not scared of those?
You think you’re so tough, so prepared for
anything, that even those anomalous beings
of pure terror can’t break
through the impenetrable
shell of your bravery?
Well...I suppose we better bring out the big
guns, then.
Just remember, when you’re huddled in the
corner, bones rattling in fear, that you brought
this on yourself.
After all, there’s no entity quite as good
at inspiring screams as SCP-2006.
So please stay awhile, and find out why this
one’s called...Too Spooky.
We’re sorry you had to hear that.
But you really can’t blame us for having
a little theatricality with this one - In
fact, having a good grasp of theatricality
is actually essential to everyone dealing
with SCP-2006.
Forget gunplay, rituals, and mind games, SCP-2006
requires Foundation-subsidised acting lessons
in order to work on his containment.
Which, even as Foundation containment methods
go, is pretty darn strange.
When you got into this line of work, you probably
expected you’d be in high-intensity battles
with SCP-682, or attending conferences on
how best to repel the menace of The Scarlet
King - Not acting out scenes from A Streetcar
Named Desire with Dr. Bright.
But believe us, it’s important work.
As they’ll probably tell you at these classes,
“There are no small parts, only small actors.”
You won’t spend time at these sessions perfecting
Shakespearian soliloquies, instead, you’ll
be adopting a much narrower focus: Learning
how to properly act and express fear.
The more convincingly scared you can appear,
the better.
Because when it comes to SCP-2006, your job
and potentially even your life depend on it.
Plus, it’s the only time that peeing your
pants and collapsing on the job may actually
get you a raise, rather than just a series
of strange looks from your co-workers.
When you pass that course with flying colors,
you’re finally ready to actually come face
to face with the Prince of Nightmares himself:
SCP-2006.
By this point, you’ve had it drilled into
your head so many times that you could never
forget it: For the love of God, whatever this
thing does, you act scared.
Don’t stonewall, don’t smile, and whatever
you do, don’t laugh.
Laughing at SCP-2006 is probably the fastest
way you can get demoted to swabbing feces
in SCP-173’s chamber.
If you know what’s good for you, you’ll
dial up that fear.
When the big day comes, you’re sent into
SCP-2006’s airtight containment chamber
with a special package.
That time of the month has come once again
- You need to deliver the goods.
You spot a television in the corner first,
still on but tuned to static.
You’re pondering what a waste of electricity
this is when SCP-2006, who’d been hiding
behind an armchair, decided to finally strike.
You barely had time to realize what was going
on when a large, dark shape suddenly blotted
out your vision.
It was over six feet tall, and it looked...Well,
it looked like a man in an exceedingly cheap
gorilla costume, except with a goofy diving
helmet with what looked like TV antennas on
top.
It waved its arms around wildly, as if to
hammer home the point that, yes, this really
was happening, and you should be terrified
by it.
The creature bellowed, “FEAR ME MORTAL.
I AM THE MIGHTY RO-MAN!
COWER IN FEAAAAAAAR!”
At that moment, your weeks of training kicked
in, almost like a reflex.
You let out an ear-piercing shriek and drop
down to the floor, desperately crawling away
from the goofy-looking creature.
Eyes wide, breathing heavy, movements frantic
and defensive.
You gather yourself up in one of the room’s
corners and curl into a ball, covering your
face.
Imbuing your voice with a well-practiced quiver,
you say, “Please mighty Ro-Man!
Don't h-hurt me!
I have so much to live for, just please, let
me go!”
The monster holds a, quote-unquote, “menacing”
pose for a few seconds longer, before slackening
into a joyful laugh.
It even extended a rubbery gorilla paw to
help you up.
Of course, you hesitate for a few seconds,
gazing fearfully, waiting for it to say.
“Ha ha ha!
It's just me, doc!
I got you pretty good, didn't I?”
And as far as he knows, yes, he did.
You’re sure to never slip into the body
language of comfort.
It’s utterly vital that SCP-2006 truly believes
that he’s scary to you, even though he looks
like a terrible monster costume from an even
worse low-budget B-Movie.
Though specifically, the Ro-Man, the monster
from the 1953 trash classic, “Robot Monster.”
You tell SCP-2006 that you’re here with
some more stimulus material for him, and hand
him a plastic bag.
When he asks you what you’ve brought him
this time, you tell him you can’t even look
at it.
If you so much as laid eyes on it, you’d
slip into a terrified state of catatonia.
You’d honestly rather look at 096 than look
at what you’ve brought him today.
SCP-2006 cocked his head to the side, and
asked, “What’s 096?”
Oh no.
The terror that was fake before wasn’t quite
so fake now.
You’d slipped up, buddy, and if you didn’t
come up with a good save quickly, you would
be in deep trouble.
You gulp and take a quick breath, trying to
compose yourself, before saying that 096 is
just another movie.
One that’s not nearly as scary as the one
you’ve prepared for him.
That seemed to satisfy him, so you internally
breathe a sigh of relief, and turn to make
your exit.
You’ve just left SCP-2006 with a DVD copy
of the 1977 “classic”, Death Bed: The
Bed That Eats.
A somewhat obscure horror movie about an evil
bed created by a demon.
That should tide the eccentric anomaly over
for another month.
So, you’re probably wondering: What actually
just happened?
What’s the logic?
What are the connections between the strange
sequence of events we all just witnessed?
While it may seem bizarre now, once you know
more about SCP-2006, it’ll all make sense.
We can’t promise it’ll actually seem any
less bizarre by the end, though.
SCP-2006 is a Keter-class shapeshifting anomaly.
Its default form is a floating sphere of about
fifty centimeters in diameter.
Not exactly terrifying - And this is actually
a big problem for SCP-2006, as the mischievous
anomaly has an almost compulsive desire to
scare people.
Not to physically harm them in any way, just
give them a good, old-fashioned spook.
He’s shown to be pretty much indestructible,
so neutralization is off the table.
You may be thinking, “He seems like a pretty
harmless goofball, why would anyone want to
neutralize him?”
And...Well, we’ll answer that one later.
Back to SCP-2006’s favorite hobby: Scaring
people.
While 2006 seems to practically live off of
giving a good scare, he’s thankfully no
Pennywise.
2006 has no inherent knowledge of what scares
humans, and thus, has to learn what scares
humans from external sources.
This unique weakness to SCP-2006’s ability
is one the Foundation has discovered an ingenious
method of exploiting for its containment:
They simply keep SCP-2006 misinformed on what
people actually find scary, tricking it to
make sure that it’s always hopelessly inept
at its hobby.
Their method of achieving this is twofold.
Firstly, they give SCP-2006 a monthly supply
of the worst horror movies you can imagine.
True bargain bucket B-movie schlock: Troll
2, Leprechaun: In The Hood, Birdemic: Shock
& Terror, The Gingerdead Man, The Beast of
Yucca Flats, Plan 9 From Outer Space, The
Creeping Terror, The Man Without a Body, Manos:
The Hands of Fate, Track of the Moon Beast,
and of course, the seminal classic, Eegah
- A movie about an evil caveman being unfrozen
and terrorizing Palm Springs.
Movies like this are a perfect mechanism for
tricking SCP-2006, because it sees the characters
in the movies reacting with fear to the terrible,
hokey monsters rampaging across backlots and
soundstages, and starts to believe that these
B-Movie beasts are actually scary.
That’s the first part of the trick, and
you’ve probably already figured out the
second half: The Foundation makes sure that
any employees who interact with SCP-2006 in
any capacity must play the part of appearing
actually, genuinely frightened by it.
This one-two punch of trickery keeps SCP-2006
successfully bamboozled.
As such, despite being a creature largely
based around creating fear - albeit, in a
more friendly, playful way than most anomalies
- it’s seen as a joke among staff members.
It wouldn’t be surprising to hear that different
staff members took turns laughing at surveillance
footage.
Or that at the latest Site Halloween Party,
a few drunken researchers tried to trick SCP-2006
into assuming the form of David S. Pumpkins
from Saturday Night Live.
As you could probably gather, developing such
an unimpressed attitude to containing anomalies
with the SCP Foundation is never a good thing.
After all, even some of the most innocent-looking
ones can hide surprisingly dark secrets.
Dr. Randall Owings, the Site Director for
Site 118 - where SCP-2006 is held - released
a stern memorandum to everyone working in
2006’s proximity.
It read:
“I have been getting reports of some of
the lax behavior regarding SCP-2006.
Many personnel have been heard laughing at
SCP-2006 during surveillance when it watches
a new movie, or when it attempts to scare
individuals.
Some personnel have been heard questioning
why SCP-2006 is classified as a Keter entity.
I am here to remind you that a Keter entity
is a Keter entity, regardless of how innocuous
it may seem.
No, SCP-2006 is not a rampaging demi-god,
nor is it a regenerating super lizard.
However, it possesses the same level of danger
as any other Keter that the Foundation has
contained.
Think of SCP-2006's purpose.
It wishes to scare people.
Imagine what would happen if SCP-2006 broke
containment, and found out what really scared
people.
Imagine if it saw the horror and fear of war,
or the concepts of paranoia or phobias common
to each and every human being.
Imagine if it found the true horror of a nuclear
holocaust or an XK-Class scenario.
Now couple that with an entity that possesses
shape-shifting abilities with no known limits,
and you'll understand why it's classified
as Keter.
All personnel mentioned above have been suitably
disciplined.
I do not want to hear about this again.”
SCP-2006 is only as harmless as the Foundation’s
containment procedures allow it to be.
It’s why it can never know about other anomalies
or any actually frightening works of fiction.
If ever SCP-2006 became aware of the true
sources of human fear, there would be no stopping
it, seeing as the creature
appears to be indestructible.
Like many of the anomalies kept under lock
and key by the SCP Foundation, it’s a ticking
time bomb that one little mistake could turn
into an utter catastrophe.
Terrible movies and theatrical staff members
need to keep SCP-2006 in the dark about what
actually scares us, because, beyond that,
the only limit to the danger of SCP-2006 is
the human imagination.
And that, my friends, is a very spooky thought
indeed.
Now go check out “SCP-426 - I am a Toaster”
and “The Horror of Body Stealing Rain - SCP-3300”
for more of the most bizarre anomalies out
there!